3-2
[Applause]
that one ate up galveston goes into left
field for base hit
boyd's starting to get it together had
two hits last night
usually you hear somebody in the dugout
say all the married men off the infield
when somebody hits a ball like this
almost took uh freddie galvez into left
field
2-2 line drive it's a base hit
lemayo will be held at third so the
yankees had the bases loaded
and nobody out the exact scenario from
last night
click though this is a hanging breaking
ball he's lucky it's only a single if
you ask me
solid line drive to left field falls in
front of hayes
balls hit so hard that the mayor
couldn't score
bonded to third there's one and there's
two a run scores but a double play
for pletco yankees have a runner at
second now with two outs
and there's gary sanchez
deep to left field there it goes
see ya a long home run for sanchez
a two-run blast and it is three-nothing
yankees
i said he's trending upward just like
this baseball
up and away and out of here that wasn't
a
bad flip it was a bad drop
that one's driven deep to left field
there it goes
sia back to back home runs by the yanks
frazier with a solo shot four-nothing
bombers
and the rest of the offense is clicking
there's no place to go for the opposing
pitchers
that was right down the middle and it is
scorched
wow beautiful swing
international league player of the year
back in 19.
right field on the move is frazier
that's a fair ball
can't come up with it mancini around
third he'll score
and the orioles are on the board an rbi
double from ryan mount castle and it's
four to one
don long been talking about we have got
to use the opposite field we got to be
able to hit the ball the other way
stay in the middle part of the field and
right down the right field line clint
frazier
almost got to it it rattles around by
the garage door down there
and he's got a base hit into right field
mount castle around third
frazier up with it fires to the plate
and mount castle's home with the second
run
rbi base hit for pedro severino the
orioles
cut the lead to 4-2
there's aaron judge he singled in the
first and then came around to score on
sanchez home run
deep to left field there it goes
see ya a long home run for
judge his fourth this series
and it gives the yankees a 5-2 lead
[Applause]
return what the orioles thought should
have been a 2-2 cat into a 3-1 cap
and judge did not miss the 3-1 he's not
missing anything you get it too much
towards the middle of the plate
this is what you're going to get
homegrown prospects like tanner scott
paul fry was acquired prior to me
getting here
um and then a lot of guys like you said
that we've picked up kind of on the
margins and and
identified and coached up and you know
they're making the most of the
opportunity
last summer or maybe a ball at the most
there we go mount castle
shot to left field hayes tags
and he will score so an rbi
for mount castle and the orioles pick up
a run and cut it to 5'3
really need to be a longer guy i i don't
know
franco fairball out in the right field
corner
mancini around third he scores
and the orioles have cut it to just one
run it's a 5-4 lead now
yeah michael franco how about that and
the orioles
have made a big effort in this series to
use the opposite field a lot of orioles
going to right field
right hand hitters that's hit well
that's a base hit
franco around third he'll score and the
orioles have tied the game
three run inning here in the third and
the birds have battled back we're tied
at five
[Applause]
balling a strike right field
it's deep off the wall
mullins into second and he'll stop there
with a double
headed a long way off the pepsi sign
just to the left of the 373 mark
and mullins on with a one-out double
rows have been much better in this
series runners in scoring position
three for five in game one just one for
seven
last night 2-2 on the way hit hard right
field
back in the corner that's gonna get the
go ahead run home mancini digging for
second he's in
mullen scores and the orioles lead at
six five
trey mancini runners in scoring position
delivers again
they battled all the way back and now
take the lead
[Applause]
six to five and there is another base
hit going the opposite way this one off
the ball mancini checks up just for a
second realize that ball hits off the
wall and gets by frazier
mancini and mount castle the ones that
are sharing first base
and the diving play by clint frazier and
he took an extra base hit
away from mancini to the delight
of peralta mancini's hit the ball well
to the opposite field in this whole
series
and he drives this one sinking away
[Applause]
somehow does not come out of the glove
a lot of runs early in this one the
orioles and yankees combined
for 10 runs in the first three innings
but only one run
since then that's the run that put gave
the orioles a lead that's hit well left
field
way back and it's out of here
franco out of a terrible slump in a big
way today
three hits and a line drive out
and the orioles extend the lead to 8-5
and he has barreled up three balls watch
him sink into his legs on this one
just goes down and punishes this ball
straight away left field
it's almost like a line drive as he
sinks into his legs
two for four in his young career with
the bases loaded there's hayes at second
mancini over at first mullins off a
third
[Applause]
up the middle into center field mullen
scores
hayes around third here comes the throw
it's cut off
and he scores ryan mount castle delivers
a two rbi base hit
and the orioles have some breathing room
now at 10 to 5.
[Applause]
the 0-2 and the yankees are still alive
there's a base hit
scoring is frazier
and duhar stops at second an rbi single
for lemayo
and it's 10-6
valdez ahead two strikes
and he got him ball game
luke voight down on strikes and the
orioles
win the final game of the series 10 to
six
big day for the orioles come back down
four to nothing they come roaring all
the way back